what advice would you give to young
people today
maybe their teenagers in high school
maybe early college
what advice would you give
to a career or have a life they can be
proud of yes
well i'd be very diffident really um
about offering any any wisdom but uh i
think
i think
they they should
they should realize that um uh
um
the choices
they make
at that time are um important and um
from the experience of
i've had and with many friends um many
people don't realize that opportunities
are open
until it's too late
they somehow think that some
opportunities are only open to a few
privileged people and they don't even
try and then that they could succeed um
but um
if i focus on people working in um
some profession i know about like
science
i would say
pick an area to work in
where new things are happening
uh where uh you can uh do something that
the old guys never had the chance to
think about um don't go into a field
that's fairly stagnant because then um
there will be much to do or you'll be
trying to tackle the problems that the
old guys got stuck on and so i think in
science um
i can give people good advice that they
should
pick a subject where there are exciting
new developments and also of course
something which
suits their style because even within
science which is just one profession um
there's a big range of style between the
sort of solution thinker the person does
field work the person who works in a big
team etc and whether you like computing
or uh mathematical thought etc so pick
some subject that suits your style and
where things are happening fast um and
uh be prepared to be flexible that's
what i'd say really keep your eyes open
for the opportunity throughout like you
said go to a new field go to the field
with new cool stuff is happening yeah
just keep your eyes open yes that's
patheticness but i think
most of us and i include myself in this
didn't realize this sort of thing as
little too late
yeah i think this applies way beyond
science um
what do you make of this finiteness of
our life
do you think about death do you think
about mortality do you think about your
mortality and are you afraid of death
well i mean i'm not afraid because i i
think i'm lucky i feel lucky to have
lata as long as i have
um and uh and to have been fairly lucky
in um
in my life in many respects compared to
to most people so i feel very fortunate
um
this reminds me of this
current uh
emphasis on uh living much longer than
the so-called altos laboratories
which have been set up by
billionaires
there's one in
san francisco one in
uh la jolla i think and one in cambridge
and uh
they're funded by
these guys who when young wanted to be
rich and now they're rich they want to
be young again they won't find that
quite so easy and do we want this i
don't know if
if there was um some
elite that was able to do much longer
than others that would be a really
fundamental kind of inequality and
i think
if it happened to everyone
then that might be an improvement it's
not so obvious
but
i i think
for my my part i think to have uh lived
as as long as most people um and had a
fortunate life is all i can expect and a
lot to be grateful for
those are all flat issues well
i am incredibly honored that you sit
down with me today i thank you so much
for life
of exploring some of the deepest
mysteries of our universe and um of our
humanity and thinking about our future
with existential risks that are before
us um it's it's a huge honor martin that
you sit with me and i really enjoyed it
and well thank you lex i thought we
couldn't go on for as long as this but
we could have gone much longer
exactly
thank you so much
you